la consecuencia más importante es el
futuro del partido republicano si no es
declarado culpable yo creo que esto va a
fortalecer su posición dentro del
partido vamos a tener más de su
demagogia populista la o sea esto que
tanto identificamos con con tramos y lo
que va creo que va a ocurrir es una una
gran lucha dentro del partido entre
aquellos que creen y que sostienen la
democracia sus instituciones por un lado
que no apoyaron las todos los argumentos
del presidente con respecto a que había
hubo un fraude o un fraude en las
últimas elecciones y por otro lado
aquellos que apoyaron osea que dijeron
que hubo un fraude y que además quieren
conservar a trump como como líder dentro
del partido y la gran pregunta es quién
una vez que una vez que el juicio ocurra
y una vez
y salga el resultado quién va a
consolidar su poder dentro del partido
me parece que en eso es importante
resaltar la figura del mitch mcconnell
que es el es el líder de la bancada
republicano republicana del senado quien
unos días después de este intento
fallido de golpe de estado dijo que
debemos responsabilizar a donald trump o
lo que pasó sería que él debe rendir
cuentas con los hechos acontecidos y hay
que tener en cuenta esto ha surgido en
los últimos ayer por en todos los medios
que mcconnell aún está diciendo que el
voto final es una cuestión de conciencia
de cada uno y que aún si votaron
que el juicio es inconstitucional como
pasó ayer igual pueden votar a favor de
la culpabilidad de trump así que y
también aclarando que él no ha decidido
aún cómo va a votar y yo creo que esto
es importante de todas maneras no hay
dudas sobre el veredicto pero creo que
va a ser importante para marcar quién va
a votar porque cosa y el poder que van a
dejarle a trump en lo que viene en el
futuro del partido del partido
republicano me parece que eso es lo más
más importante
y yo creo además que que la insurrección
creo que esto no no no no se ha
enfatizado
suficientemente pero hace a la
insurrección no iba a ser exitosa creo
que no iba y no iba a triunfar nosotros
pensamos
en muchas ocasiones de golpe de estado
en latinoamérica esto o sea no iba a ser
derrotado en ese día al día siguiente o
en dos días pero no el golpe estado no
iba a ser exitoso pero me parece que la
principal historia que tendría que ser
un rechazo de los resultados electorales
no reconocer que los resultados fueron
obtenidos claramente en un proceso
limpio seguro sin fraude y eso no es
solamente trump sino también muchos
senadores y representantes que se adif y
que se adhirieron al argumento de trump
o sea en una democracia cuando ésta
empieza a fallar una de las principales
cuestiones es no aceptar los resultados
electorales y creo que eso es lo más
importante de todo este
de todo este juicio político y de lo que
ha ocurrido